am 20 jänner 2018 hat die türkei eine
militärische offensive auf die kurdische
enklave afr ihn in nordsyrien gestartet
offiziell wird das damit begründet dass
man eine 30 kilometer breite
sicherheitszone einrichten möchte um die
türkei vor grenzüberschreitenden
terrorismus zu schützen
heute in verächtlicher kompakt die
türkische offensive in syrien
[Musik]
der verlauf des bürgerkrieges in syrien
war aber das gegenteil von dem was man
sich in ankara erwartet hatte die
türkische regierung hatte schließlich
auf einen raschen sturz von präsident
assad gesetzt
man unterstützte massiv die politische
und militärische opposition doch es kam
ganz anders
3,4 millionen syrischer flüchtlinge
strömten in das land die türkei
errichtete er einen zaun entlang der 80
kilometer langen grenze um ein
überschreiten des krieges zu verhindern
und den weiteren ansturm von
flüchtlingen unter kontrolle zu bringen
dass er starken der kurden die einen
großteil des grenzgebietes zu türkei
besiedlung war allerdings nicht
aufzuhalten insbesondere die pkk
der deklarierte feind der türkei gewarnt
immer mehr an einfluss und position als
auslöser für die affen sie wird daher
auch angesehen dass die usa gemeinsam
mit den kurden die aufstellung einer
30.000 mann grenzschutztruppe
angekündigt haben eine rote linie für
die türkei der türkische vorstoß in den
kann thomas frieden der zu 80 prozent
von kurden besiedelt wird stellt
militärisch betrachtet die dritte phase
einer größeren operation da war sie
einst war schon im august 2016 als in
der operation euphrat schielt die türkei
gemeinsam mit lokalen verbündeten
milizen den islamischen staat aus der
gegend nördlich von aleppo zurückdrängte
und dabei ging es primär darum ein
zusammenwachsen des kurdischen gebietes
zu verhindern
die phase 2 ereignete sich im oktober
2017 die türkei brachte eigene drucken
südlich von afrika entstellung das war
mit den stärksten milizen in idlib
abgesprochen afr ihn war damit in hohem
maße eingeschlossen
mit zwanzigster jänner hat nun die phase
3 begonnen in der operation olivenzweig
soll gemeinsam mit lokalen verbündeten
die pkk hochburg vreni robert werden
gewissermaßen vor allem aber gilt es
einen 30 kilometer breiten
sicherheitsstreifen einzurichten
es ist davon auszugehen dass das mit
russland abgesprochen wurde präsident
assad hat dagegen heftig
riskiert die usa rufen wiederum zur
mäßigung auf sie sind wir mit einem teil
der kurden verbündet somit stellt sich
die frage nach einer vierten oder
fünften phase dieser militärischen
operation
der türkische präsident hat er mehrfach
angekündigt dass er anspruch erhebt auf
das gesamte territorium westlich des
euphrat im nördlichen syrien
er hat angekündigt seine truppen
richtung man beach das zentrum in dieser
region vor marschieren zu lassen
allerdings das wird nicht so einfach
sein in man beach sitzen us kräfte und
us verbündete
daher ist ein vorgehen in diesen raum
nur nach absprache mit den usa denkbar
dass türkische vorgehen birgt auch
erhebliche risiken stellt sich daher die
frage nach den möglichen ziehen sie zu
den ankaras hier werde zu nennen eine
einschränkung der autonomie der kurden
in nordsyrien ein sicherheitsgewinn an
der grenze ein aktiver kampf gegen die
pkk nicht nur im nordirak und in der
türkei sondern auch in syrien eine
positionierung in einem nachkriegs
syrien um dort eine bedeutende rolle
spielen zu können und nicht zu vergessen
eine rückkehr von flüchtlingen vom
türkischen territorien
es lässt sich noch nicht absehen welche
ergebnisse die operation olivenzweig
bringen wird das hängt nicht nur von der
türkischen risikobereitschaft ab sondern
auch vom russischen wohlwollen und vom
verhalten aus satz nicht zu vergessen
die usa insbesondere dann wenn es in
richtung man beach geht hier muss eine
gewisse einigung erzielt werden können
allerdings sei 2016 hat die türkei klar
gestellt dass sie bereit ist ihre
interessen in syrien direkt militärisch
zu vertreten
die operation olivenzweig ist nur eine
bestätigung dessen